[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro 17 8 culture une
culture toujours présente qui s'adapte
face à la crise sanitaire
au sommaire aujourd'hui au lycée saint
augustin du saint germain en laye trente
deux élèves ont choisi l'option comédie
musicale la petite troupe se prépare à
jouer les aventures d' oliver twist en
juin prochain
au programme chant danse théâtre et mise
en scène vous découvrirez les coulisses
des répétitions
l'association ciné images lance la
première édition de son challenge
chansons le principe créer une mélodie
pour un texte de crise sheldon objectif
mettre en avant la lecture et les écrits
un concours ouvert aux amateurs comme
aux professionnels
et puis en 2020 le prix clara
récompenser cet adolescent alors l'ex
ils ont été publiés dans un recueil en
novembre dernier une yvelinoise de
figure parmi les lauréats de ce concours
d'écriture destiné aux moins de 18 ans
célia gars tsongo journalistes pour télé
78 viendra nous ont parlé en plateau et
je vous le disais en titre le collège
saint-augustin situé à saint germain en
laye dispose d'une classe de quatrième
en option comédie musicale un projet
pour découvrir à l'art de la scène
trente deux élèves ont choisi de
participer au programme chant danse
théâtre et mise en scène
[Musique]
les élèves de cette classe du collège
saint-augustin ont choisi de suivre une
option comédie musicale objectif
présenter oliver twist dans un théâtre
une idée d'eleanor là-bas professeur
principal de la classe
le projet s'articule autour de deux axes
être acteur et être spectateur les
élèves des ateliers pour essayer de
progresser et de pouvoir monter leur
spectacle et à côté de ça normalement
ils ont gelé vit normalement parce
qu'elle est un donné le contexte
sanitaire c'est un peu compliqué mais
normalement ils ont la possibilité
d'aller voir des comédies musicales des
spectacles la dynamique de l'option se
retrouve au sein de l'ensemble des cours
en français on étudie les aventures de
oliver twist de charles dickens en
éducation musicale les élèves
travaillent autour de la comédie
musicale en arts plastiques qui vont
travailler sur le décor du spectacle en
eps y travaille particulièrement la
danse une discipline triple qui englobe
aussi bien le chant la danse et le
théâtre pour travailler le spectacle de
fin d'année un professionnel intervient
dans le cadre d'ateliers hebdomadaires
aller justement française
[Musique]
je viens tous les vendredis en ce moment
donné des ateliers donc de deux heures
pour essayer de mettre en place cette
comédie musicale c'est un projet assez
ambitieux avec des enfants qui pour
beaucoup n'ont pas fait de comédie
musicale qui est l'art qui mélange les
trois disciplines théâtre chant danse
mais je suis tombé sur des élèves très
motivés
au total trente deux élèves ont choisi
de participer à ce projet ils ont été
sélectionnés sur motivation en 5e on
avait une option arts vivants et ça
s'était bien passé du coup j'ai voulu
continuer à catherine comme c'est
vraiment un projet commun à la classe on
peut même révisé pendant le repas et
tout vent c'est bien parce qu'on est un
peu tous solidaires on se connaît on se
contrôle tous les jours donc bah en fait
c'est aussi beaucoup ensemble qu'on fait
les artistes en herbe se prépare à
présenter la comédie musicale oliver
twist le mardi 8 juin 2021 au théâtre
alexandre dumas un projet culturel et
solidaire puisque l'ensemble des
bénéfices récoltés grâce à la vente de
billets pour le spectacle de fin d'année
sera reversée à l'association imagine
fort margot qui lutte contre le cancer
de l'enfant et on reste dans le domaine
de la musique avec l'association du ch
l'oise signé images qui a lancé la
première édition de son challenge sans
son objectif mettre en avant la lecture
et l'écriture on écoute est la
présidente de l'association claudine
aumont qui nous explique le principe
en contexte actuel les musiciens ne
pouvait pas trop se produire en
s'exhibant autant confie t de ce temps
pour leur proposer les créations et ce
challenge on propose donc au compositeur
interprète un texte écrit par le
barrouyer cris sheldon
il doit avant composé la musique
enregistrée et musique et les paroles
voilà voilà et nous l'envoyer sous
format mp4 la qualité de
l'enregistrement le vin bien le texte
doit être ne doit pas être modifié
on doit le texte la chanson doit être
gardée après bon aussi le la qualité de
la musique
[Musique]
soyez créatifs et puis amusez vous
apprenez plaisir à nous envoyer de la
musique on ennuie de ses tics le chaland
chanson est ouvert jusqu'au 15 mars les
démos sont envoyés en format mp4 sur
l'adresse mail suivante challenge at
signé images point fr un jury composé de
six personnes choisira les trois
meilleurs projets ils interpréteront
leur travail devant le public du salon
de livre de buch les le 25 avril
prochain
plus d'informations sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
cette nouvelle ont été écrites par des
adolescents et regroupées dans un livre
publié par les éditions fleurus
le prix clara est un concours d'écriture
destiné aux moins de 18 ans il a été
fondé en 2006 par les éditions héloïse
d'ormesson en mémoire de clara une jeune
fille décédée
à 13 ans des suites d'une malformation
cardiaque et qui aimait beaucoup
l'écriture est celle yaga tsongo bonsoir
comment ça et vous vous allez justement
nous en parler vous pouvez peut-être
nous expliquer comment participent à ce
concours
oui bah déjà comme vous l'avez dit il
première règle il faut avoir entre 13 et
17 ans et finalement c'est un peu la
seule à respecter puisque aucun thème
n'est imposé
chaque année le jury composé d'éditeurs
d'écrivains ou de journaliste reçoit
entre 280 et 300 textes
autre règle cela doit être une nouvelle
avec une intrigue qui se suffit à
elle-même et l'année 2020 qui est marqué
par la crise sanitaire vient finalement
les adolescents pour autant ne se sont
pas inspirés de ces temps moroses
d'après claire renaut et l'éditrice des
éditions fleurus
dans le contenu des textes c'était très
très divers très très ouvert sur le
monde
ça faisait voyager dans le temps et dans
l'espace
on sent qu'ils ont eu envie de
s'échapper de s'échapper par l'écriture
de sortir de leur monde et d'en créer un
autre et donc l'année 2020 décerné sept
gagnants
oui sept gagnants qui ont écrit des
nouvelles complètement différente
on a des récits intimes
on a aussi des choses mises en vert on a
des récits historiques ont à de la
science fiction
il ya du tout vraiment pas de contrainte
ni de genre ni le style est dense et
l'oréal il ya une jeune yvelinoise de 17
ans célia oui elle s'appelle camille
chéron elle vient de toussus-le-noble sa
nouvelle intitulée et s'il s'était
trompé raconte l'histoire d'une jeune
fille aveugle dans un petit village dans
le jura qui suite à une rencontre avec
un vieux monsieur du village voisin
forme une sorte de relation construction
et arrive à avancer dans l'est ce jeu
mais prendre une nouvelle avec un an va
dire une sorte de morale derrière ou en
tout cas un message que jose en tout cas
quand on l'a vu on peut en tirer quelque
chose
donc j'essaie de prendre un peu tout ce
qui me tenait à coeur
puis j'ai pris un petit peu d
inspiration un peu par ci par là et je
vais essayer de tenter quelque chose
avec description plutôt sensorielles ou
caisse quand elle touche quelque chose
que ce qu'elle ressent quand les bruits
et c'est là dessus que s'est construit
ma nouvelle le recueil de nouvelles est
tirée justement à 5000 exemplaires les
inscriptions au concours de 2021 sont
déjà ouverts vous pouvez donc vous
inscrire et envoyer vos textes par email
à prix clara @ fleurus editions.com est
important les bénéfices sont
intégralement reversés à l'hôpital
necker pour les recherches sur les mares
les maladies cardiaques que chez les
enfants
merci ces liens pour fausses
informations on retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
cette culture et oui avec plaisir les
scènes de spectacles sont encore fermés
mais les répétitions continuent au
théâtre du prisme à à elancourt lionel
hoche et sa compagnie mais mes banjo et
aides en résidence en décembre le
reportage de célia gâte son goût
[Musique]
foi de défense
dimanche éperdument nouveau spectacle de
lionel h et sa compagnie mais mes banjo
depuis début décembre ils sont en
résidence de création au théâtre du
président à elancourt accompagnés par la
mission de danse de saint quentin en
yvelines
une oeuvre musicale en trois parties et
qui mêle trois personnages sur scène
dans un environnement manière et c'est
une petite épopée d'une
via un duo d'un côté puis un personnage
un peu un peu fantomatique de l'autre
qui reflète peut-être un peu un état du
monde qui ressemble étrangement à ce
qu'on vit une manière très métaphorique
et onirique et puis soudainement on
arrive dans un univers très coloré qui
est l'endroit de tous les possibles
dans dimanche éperdument beaucoup de
chansons en live avec des répertoire de
standards de jazz assez connu
[Musique]
il est pas réservé à une élite ou à une
façon de comprendre l'art contemporain
c'est un endroit qui accueille tout tout
et chacun est l'idée c'est de vraiment
de se laisser emporter par cette part
cette vision des choses par ces
personnages qui sont là et par ce monde
un peu étrange mystérieux prévue pour le
15 janvier la date de représentation a
été repoussée à mai 2021
si les conditions sanitaires et les
décisions gouvernementales le permettent
alex plus de faim est à la fois
réalisateur acteur chanteur et humoriste
yvelinois il a sorti plusieurs albums et
bien de réaliser seule une web série de
11 épisodes
ils sont disponibles est en cours de
diffusion sur sa chaîne youtube
il était l'invité d'astrid bergère dans
l'émission 10 pts de lundi regarder on
va faire l'amour avant tu finis alors
laisse moi un message était intéressé je
tenais les coronavirus ni aucune est
resté hashtag opportuniste
jeudi
c'est clair
[Musique]
le pitch concret c'est ben un humoriste
comme par hasard qui s'en vient pour le
confinement et qui du coup décide de
faire un concert en live pour les
internautes il fait son concert c'est
une catastrophe le concert puisque
forcément n'y a pas d'interaction que le
public
c'est pitoyable et à la fin ça finit il
fait une chaussure sur le coronel virus
et du coup il ya un internaute qui
réagit super mal en menaçant en disant
c'est pas drôle de machin ça s'enflamme
et il lui dit je vais te crever et donc
après le mec se dit il va
peut-être venir chez moi s'il trouve où
j'habite chez mal quoi et c'est ce qui
se passe le mec s'est fait enfermé dans
une cave par ce gars là il se réveille
c'est fait
ray aurait assommé et du cou
et du coup il se réveille et il ya ce
mec là qui le titille le château de
versailles vient de dévoiler le toit de
la chapelle royale
l'information vient d'être publiée sur
le compte twitter du monument historique
l'édifice est en rénovation depuis près
de trois ans les sculptures ont été
restaurés quant aux travaux ils sont
toujours en cours sur la partie basse du
bâtiment et devraient prendre fin au
printemps 2021 et c'est la fin de ce
cette sculpture merci de nous avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour vous présenter les
initiatives culturelles du département
et d'ici là portez vous bien
[Musique]